[Music]
so i have a story here
of this woman named stephanie
who is a youtuber and
her youtube channel has been pretty
popular recently
and she and thanks to her youtube
channel she's able to
pay her bills at her 40
room french chateau holy [ __ ]
yeah wait is that like a french bed and
breakfast
so she actually bought this 15 years ago
with her two
ex-boyfriends two and at the same time
yes what so she's a mastermind not the
same like they weren't together same
time no no so
so one of the ex-boyfriends she has two
ex-boyfriends that's
that's money and and went into business
yeah
yeah there's three partners yeah three
partners on the paper
so she did that she purchased this with
her then boyfriend i believe so that's
one of the guys
and then the other guy they had dated i
don't know when i don't know their
history but at that time when they
purchased the chateau they were already
exes but they were best friends and so
yeah especially if you're her current
boy that's really good
yeah but but the crazy thing is like i
said they purchased a chateau 15 years
ago
they've been working on it she was
running it as a bed and breakfast but
then the pandemic hit
so she had to close down her chateau um
but the thing is
back in 2018 she participated in a
uk reality show where they showcased
brits um working on french
chateaus that they purchase so like
restore things
people doing that that you can have a
reality tv show yeah so she was featured
in that show and she
like people really liked her so then she
decided to open up her own youtube
channel
and then thanks to that youtube channel
it has
helped her maintain her chat
40 bedroom chat through the views but
she also has a patreon
and i think she's getting 22 000 a month
through her
and the patreon is like solely to put
into the chateau to continue
restoring it beautiful yeah right now
and so she also
she also keeps it working with
volunteers and she works with like her
mom
and those two boyfriends a historical
like
thing that like it's [ __ ] nice 16th
century yeah
that makes sense it's like keeping a
castle yeah
and she actually purchased it from a
member of the family who had had it in
their family for all that time
yeah i don't know oh i don't know
but i do know that she's going redfin no
so i do know that she
said that at that time that she was
living
in london and so she had her own
apartment
and so she said that her boyfriend at
that time
which is now oh no no her ex-boyfriend
her best friend had his own apartment
too
and so for the the cost of selling both
apartments in london
is what they put into the chateau wow
like that's how much it
it it was worth so the wasteland was
that cheap the way she said
it is that it was really really cheap
yeah wow and so she's been spending
all these 15 years like working on it
and like i said
she did have it as a bed and breakfast
in the past and the interesting thing
too is that
like her boyfriend at that time when
they signed like they broke up they're
no longer
together but he still is involved with
the chateau
to the point where now his his now wife
and daughter
they all work on it all working on it
too and then so
she's like the new wife or like the wife
then um
she's she decided like oh we're during
the pandemic we're spending it at the
chateau
like we're gonna be there and it just
seems like they just all have a really
great relationship and everyone
interesting
gets along really well and they all have
this like love for the chateau
oh yeah that's what i see here that says
um when whenever the new wife and
the ex see each other they go hello
this is great good to see you yeah wow
it's great
stupid what a good arrangement in a
london accent yeah
no so hello is the chateau beautiful
it's
really pretty um i'll show you in a sec
so this is oh wait that's the wrong
wow she's getting money out the ass and
it's not even open
uh well yeah because of her patreon dude
sick that's it [ __ ] yeah and then i
opened the only fans from my chateau
no so she also has volunteers living in
the chateau and like throughout all
these years
she's always had volunteers like cycle
through so they'll
they'll trade their their practice their
expertise
for room and board so then like that's
how she's able to work on the chateau a
lot too
this is stephanie oh wow oh my god wow
for the price of two apartments in
london
castle yeah 40 rooms dude somebody's
like [ __ ] i'm dumping this piece of
[ __ ] this
it has a lot of spiders oh you have a
[ __ ]
what is that a carriage yeah and then
like here are some of the people that
live there and like
her mom and her her the new husband and
like
yeah then so this channel is called the
chateau diaries and i actually got
sucked in yesterday i was watching so
many
episodes because like it's just so
interesting seeing like
the entire like a tour of the chateau
for example it's just like
really heartwarming seeing how much she
loves
every inch of that place because she's
put her heart and soul in every
room why because princesses love castles
and [ __ ] that's why
she was raised with that kind of
mentality too many disney movies
sick actually no actually that's super
toxic super wrong and toxic no i could
tell you how she was raised so her
parents
um they purchased a home in britain
so she said she was she knows that she
grew up
in a large home in england after her
british father and french mother bought
a large country estate and set about
making it into a home for all
alzheimer's patients so her parents were
both nurses
believed living in a beauty and
beautiful surroundings would be
beneficial for the patients
so that's when the family moved into the
attic and then placed the
patients in the main house below so she
grew up with having a lot of people
around her and stuff and in a big place
so she's really happy dude that's
hilarious she's like
yeah i got a castle for my patients
actually hope that's okay with you guys
i'm gay
stupid the funny thing is like yeah but
i live in the attic
it's like they live in the dungeon or
the [ __ ] jail of the
castle and they let everyone else live
in like the room oh her house her
room and or she calls it an apartment
and at the chateau it's like really nice
i'd call an apartment too if it's
the grand master but bedroom or whatever
because when i picture
france right like i picture it being
like all cute and beautiful
like that and when i picture england i
picture game of thrones like
rugged like stone and cold and dark and
she says the chateau is hella cold like
yeah but it's beautiful looking right so
like it looks warm and nice it's it's
it's different from like british style
maybe bring like a tinder hook up there
i can see it i mean you have experience
i don't know i think i think you guys
would start [ __ ] at the gate
can't even make it to the chateau yep
cold or not
i so i've done a ton of research on
nicholas cage [ __ ]
yeah so he uh he's an interesting fellow
also because i did a whole podcast about
it for me and he showed that they don't
tell you
yeah that's a reason right but um so
he owns a castle and the biggest thing
about castle
is that there's no [ __ ] heating so
it's like a super pain in the ass and it
costs a
[ __ ] ton of heat a ton dude yeah a lot
because of the old masonry and all those
other kinds
yeah but people were used to that kind
of weather back then you know what i
mean like
they acclimated right and then they wore
like
what thousands of layers and you had a
fireplace in every [ __ ] room
and you had like 30 people just to run
the fire
you don't have the torches on every wall
yeah that's the ancient ancients that's
for life it's the game of thrones
i heard even buckingham palace is still
cold i heard it's cold as [ __ ] too
and i heard it's not even that great
they can't install like a
hac or a heater in there i think it's
just the way that all these things were
originally built
ain't got space it wasn't to facilitate
it is using super old world thinking too
but also not to facilitate like
just style not airflow and all kinds of
[ __ ]
yeah cause they they used a lot of
marvel too like or at least in
in france france because remember we
went to the palace of versailles like
there was a lot of rooms that was just
all marble and it was [ __ ] cold in
there
like there's just zero but there's a lot
of blankets
a lot of blankets do you know the
history of this [ __ ] where it's like
this is a prince who lived here and all
i did was his family and some [ __ ]
jesus you know the history of your cell
phone not being on airplane mode
sorry it's my father-in-law dunking on
me because my coleslaw is fine
you got your father-in-law that's right
take your time
he's a rams fan i can't wait to see what
happens this weekend they didn't have
bathrooms
at the at the palace of her side yeah
but they didn't no back then it was just
they had the chamber pots oh yeah they
come out
of this yeah um yeah so she actually in
her vlogs she has a little intro about
the chateau so she says that it belonged
to some
family that was very prominent with like
french royalty somehow but they
they weren't french i don't i don't know
the exact thing but
she gets refreshing it got to the point
where because i don't remember i didn't
say that information
but it um it got to a point where a
family member of that family got invited
by one of the kings to go greet marie
antoinette
so like they have like at least that
historical of let them eat cake fan
it's like one of their family members
was one time
um able to go pet the horse of the king
something like something like a
neighbor's neighbor you know yeah
he was the gesture who got murdered yeah
but
i don't know i i got sucked in but it's
also really cool to know that
thanks to youtube and and people that
were fans like in patreon yeah like she
was able to
keep keep her her chateau running do you
guys understand
do you guys understand the royal system
in like
england so like prince of wales blah
blah blah you can become a lord
yeah if you own land there like there's
like
yeah this day yeah what how do you own
land but it's
it depends on the land yeah well if you
yeah if you own like a certain house
you can have a like a like a household
or whatever or you could
transfer titles and then there's
families that are like
prestigious or whatever they have royal
whatever but they're like
broke because they're like i don't want
this big ass [ __ ] castle man you know
how much taxes i got
overhead dude so they turn them into
museums or whatever or like they have
homes and they're like i don't [ __ ]
pay it like
how does it work with like the prince of
wales and all those other goddamn trees
of wales i remember that's a title
so that's just whoever's next in line
because i asked this question too i was
like
is it really a prince of welsh people
but it's not
it's just a title for the king so it's
like
a a thing but it's two columns yeah so
being a lord is [ __ ] though yeah
it's that isn't that just you have land
well in the past it meant something it's
like being a doctor but like you're
you're a psychologist
but if someone comes up
like can i slap him no there's no it's
just it's it's just something that's
used to be a system that no one gives a
[ __ ] about anymore but it still exists
there's people that actually go by
lord elliot or something yeah yeah yeah
yeah people go by like sir
uh elton john for example because he got
knighted well he was knighted
yeah no right i want to go [ __ ] john
master williams sean connelly yeah
yeah yeah you just said his name weird
disease by sir
so he said his own name dude
yeah i want to know more about me and
he's like actually it's lord or sir i'ma
slap them
dude if you were a lord
respect me if it was sir paul mccartney
and you're like what's up paul
and he corrected you would you slap mr
mccarthy
what's his name oh my god oh my god paul
[Music]
do